Willie Murphy is a 77 year old
grandmother and you may have seen this
viral video of her she is a weightlifter
a power trainer and she's just got a
great spirit and she's got some pretty
kick-ass muscles let's take a look so I
started the weight training so little by
little I got stronger and stronger so
this is the gun would go off boom
I touched those ladies that was four
years ago and since then I have been a
competitive power lifter the audience
would say oh that old lady and she
lifting and they say oh and I and guess
what my car got stuck I'm pushing my car
which is a fabulous thing power lifting
my grandchildren I can lift them up
without any problem and the best of all
I don't need any help when I'm carrying
my groceries you see that's what it's
about it's about life and ify life I
mean if you don't love that woman I
really don't know what to say to you
everything about her not only the
physical stuff but her empowerment her
self empowerment the sense of humor even
the way she speaks and yes all about L
IFE
life life life just I just love it when
you see videos like that do you think I
could be that person or do you think oh
I'm already it's too late for me
I've been to the gym in three months so
what I love her you ever maybe I should
go to the gym now maybe you need her as
a trainee I do that she'd probably be a
hell of a trainer I would listen though
you she seems wife and it's nice to get
advice from a grandmother don't you
think sure I mean I definitely think
that grandma can kick my ass I don't
know to what end when I see these
stories I'm like I'm always wondering
what does she know that we don't know
like why is she so buff at that age
what's coming I think she knows that
well time to lift your own stuff and
pull your car and push your car when I
met old I plan on being very laid-back
like even more so than I am now yeah
because you're very high-strung right
now yeah but I mean like I'm not saying
I'm not saying I'm very active and I
want to be even less active as I get
further along in life yeah would you
guys rather live a life of carelessness
and freedom and whatever you want to
call it and drop dead at 80 or more
conservative life and get those last 20
years and go to the even hundreds thing
between the two to be honest so you want
90 you want a little bit of fun just
lift a 45 pound weight yeah she's doing
she's doing a lot what do you think we
do medical science will get us to a
point where we can not exercise and live
to be 120 anyway that's the dream right
that is that I don't want to be a 76
year old weightlifter right you just
want to take a pill yeah that'll get you
there what I was thinking when I was
watching this though is that we're so
quick to dismiss and and mock old people
in society all the time right we see
this all the time people someone old on
telly I mean people get phased out of
television all the time where we should
be learning from old people they've been
around the block more than us right why
are we so quick to dismiss old people I
don't think I'm the right person to ask
because I you know I feel sad for when
people are mean to old people and the
elderly and disrespectful and I don't
think we should be that way yeah why do
you think we are though because we're
I don't know just fundamentally
human sir why do they also tend to have
a lot more old-fashioned views not all
the time but a lot of the time so it can
be it can be frustrating to argue or
debate with an old person about many
issues that kind of we see is common
sense that they see as being completely
backwards right although I think a lot
of that's even changing we did it we did
a thing last week about those three
grandmas that took bong hits I don't
know if you guys saw the viral video on
that which was pretty great there's
plenty of videos out there about older
people that are now completely okay with
gay marriage I'll answer that I guess
that's the beauty of the internet maybe
it's speeding things up a little bit my
grandparents are okay with gay marriage
and they're okay with a lot of things
that I thought they wouldn't be because
they're over 90 yeah but are they dead
lifting like no they should yours
they're all dead but I mean I'm not
saying we shouldn't give them a chance
certainly give everyone a chance to kind
of evolve with their views yeah I think
a lot of the the kind of discomfort that
we get with another generation is that
we feel like they're kind of removed
from what we understand as like being
our society now of versus what they kind
of appreciate it to be theirs